today we're going to be carrying on our
section that we call 10-minute thesis
and talk about the problem of entropy in
an expanding universe perhaps in the
universe that underwent a hyperactive
expansion known as inflation that we
talked about in several videos in this
series
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from the magic
i like to read from a quote from t.s
eliot who said what we call the
beginning is often the end
and to make an end is to make a
beginning the end is where we start from
we're going to talk about the universe
as it's come to be today and also some
questions about what do we do about the
arrow of time this problem of the
seeming low entropy required to explain
why we have high entropy today in the
universe the universe if you extrapolate
back in time must have had
extraordinarily low entropy we've talked
about that in the context of fine-tuning
problems in return of the god hypothesis
and our conversation with stephen c
meyer
we'll talk about it from a cosmological
perspective in upcoming videos where we
talk about the board guthful lincoln a
challenge to
the notion that the universe had a
pre-existing cycle
to our current observable epoch namely a
singularity theorem as it's sometimes
called but we always have to confront
the issue the problem of entropy we
consider the early universe we can
really only do what are called thought
experiments envision what the universe
might have been at its earliest moments
beyond what we can see with the two
refracting telescopes we're born with in
our head namely our eyes we have to
augment that with perhaps theoretical
imagination the way i always love to
illustrate this is within this famous
woodcut which is colorized shown here
camille falmerion the atmosphere the
popular meteorology from 1888 long
before we even had a concept of the big
bang let alone what the universe might
have looked like in an early state
because they thought the universe had
existed essentially for all time
nowadays can we do much better and what
does the universe look like as we go
back in time is it cold and foreboding
with icicles and so forth perhaps if you
ascribe to a certain cosmogeny a certain
theme a thesis for how the universe
might have started off its history but
in reality we know that the big bang
itself was very hot so at some period of
time you have to explain why the
universe could have had an early epoch
to form the lightest elements on the
periodic table of the elements namely
hydrogen helium and their isotopes but
then also simultaneously have very low
entropy
so we normally think of entropy as
disorder created by the dissipation of
heat and that's been thought about for a
long time and we'll discuss what is
entropy and what does it mean in this
lecture the universe exhibits a striking
degree of uniformity in 1965 these two
radio astronomers arno penzias and
robert wilson discovered a persistent
thermal glow of microwaves emanating
from all directions from where they
looked out in new jersey at all times of
year and all times of day no matter
which direction they looked
and eventually they realized that what
they were seeing was not just pure noise
from their instrument it was actually in
cosmic noise the random thermal
agitation
of matter and its interaction in
equilibrium with radiation that we would
later call the cosmic microwave
background radiation
this map that they made has lately
gotten a lot of upgrades courtesy of
kobe wmap and the plank experiments as
well as many experiments on the ground
like act and like polar bear simon's
array and like the south pole telescope
and in so doing we've mapped out not
only the amount of variation across the
sky of its temperature but also of its
polarization and we've measured
exquisitely precisely the e-mode
polarization as well as the b-mode
polarization which comes from
gravitational lensing of massive amounts
of dark matter in between us and the
surface of last scattering
we have yet to detect the harbinger
so-called harbinger or smoking gun of
inflation that we've talked about in
previous videos that's known as b mode
polarization that's been the focus of my
career since starting the bicep 1
experiment in 2001. it's the 20th
anniversary of that experiment and we'll
talk about how we can go after the b
mode signature from the hypothesized
inflationary paradigm in future videos
and make contra distinction between that
and observations that would be
consequent from a universe which does
not have an inflationary origin the
question is how far back beyond the cmb
can you go
so can you look back to the origin of
time itself perhaps not but we don't
need to necessarily in the inflationary
paradigm i like to think of it as going
back in time from today
all the way back to this epoch that we
call inflation but we do not know for
sure took place and that's part of our
job as experimental cosmologists to
approach it dispassionately i haven't
always been great about doing that as i
talk about in my book losing the nobel
prize
which you can get everywhere books are
sold and i talk about the candid
influence that confirmation buys had on
me in particular
but ignoring that we are now chastened
by the bicep2 experience to go after the
waves of gravity or perhaps consider
alternative origin mechanisms for how
the universe could have achieved the
solution
to the flatness horizon monopole problem
and other problems that inflation was
designed or retrodicted if you will to
address and it has been stunningly
successful and become the real dominant
paradigm in cosmology so we want to take
a baby picture of the early universe we
want to start from an image that is 10
to the plus 13 seconds old namely 380
000 years in age of the cosmos and go
back to at this extremely early epoch
perhaps a fraction of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a trillionth of a second
and i always make the analogy it's hard
to do that uh maybe infinitely more hard
than to go from the picture of a
blastocyst and predict what you would
look like something like three billion
seconds later
uh in the image that you would turn out
to be with the images that we're trying
to make of the cosmic background
radiation today we're trying to go back
a factor of 10 to the 50th so it's
exponentially hard we have discussed the
concomitant relationship between the
multiverse and inflation and here are
shown in their own words quotes from two
leading pioneers of inflation one the
originator of the inflationary idea at
least in the west alan guth
and he has a quote here it's hard to
build models of inflation that don't
lead to a multiverse and evidence for
inflation will be pushing us in the
direction of taking the idea of a
multiverse seriously
andre linde at stanford his counterpart
has said in most models of inflation if
inflation is there then the multiverse
is there it's possible to invent models
of inflation that do not allow a
multiverse but it's difficult
so any experiment that brings us closer
to confidence in inflationary theory
brings us much closer to hints that the
multiverse is real so the stakes could
not be higher because if the multiverse
exists that has dramatic ramifications
not only for astronomy for physics but
for metaphysics theology and all of
philosophy
so it's incredibly important to think
about the evolution of the universe and
how we can ascribe to it perhaps the
arrow of time and the question is what
chose the arrow's direction to begin
with
the first person to hint at a multiverse
was lucretius
who wrote as i show here
that the universe could effectively come
about an arrangement that would create
our universe from tiny little atoms
jumbling all about and he's also the
originator of some of the earliest
thoughts about atomic
thesis
now ludwig boltzmann also had concepts
of the universe and in fact the role
that entropy would play he said the
following must then be in the universe
which is in thermal equilibrium as a
whole and therefore dead here and there
relatively small regions of the size of
our galaxy which we will call worlds so
they thought in this time that the
universe was effectively our galaxy
which during the relatively short time
of eons deviates significantly from
thermal equilibrium
among these worlds the state of
probability increases as often as it
decreases so what do we observe in the
universe we observe that eggs break they
don't spontaneously re-form themselves
jump out of the pan
we observe that coffee and cream
thoroughly mixed together and you never
see them
mix apart into separate cream and coffee
which would be decreasing their entropy
but time doesn't have a direction
encoded in the fundamental laws of
physics themselves in other words if you
look at the planets you can't tell from
just an observation of the planets if
you're looking at them from below say
the plane of the solar system whether or
not they're moving forwards in time or
backwards in time in other words the
laws of newtonian gravity are invariant
under the reversal of time
and the arrow of motion that they point
in namely their momentum
so a pendulum swinging back and forth is
impossible to determine in which state
it originally began as long as you watch
the movie in reverse the pendulum will
obey the exact same laws of physics that
it does in the quote unquote forward
direction
but this is mysterious because at the
atomic level at least of thermodynamics
that we don't have to go to the quantum
level the molecular motion that we call
heat is essentially that of billiard
balls crashing together and the more
energetic the billiard ball the more
they will escape from the coffee surface
and become steam but here you see this
mixing that we would associate as heat
and thinking about as little billiard
balls why should there be a direction
associated with their collective
phenomena rather than
the fact that it springs out from
something intrinsic in other words if
the balls themselves don't have an arrow
of time how can the collection of all
these individual balls then exhibit an
hour of time that we call heat
dissipation it's been said on my podcast
by none other than frank wilcheck that
effectively time is what clocks measure
and then clocks measure things that
change so i like to call a clock an
entropometer
and again you can't tell the direction
of any of these objects intrinsically
just by looking at them if i didn't call
it to your attention to look at their
initial conditions you have no idea
which side of the pendulum they existed
they started off their swing on clocks
are the same your heart is the same
objects like pulsars in the distant
universe behave this way as well so we
don't understand the general behavior of
entropy we do understand it in
several different circumstances
pertinent to cosmology
namely we understand the thermal
radiation that would eventually become
the causing background radiation we can
calculate how much entropy the universe
has in the form of matter in the form of
light we can calculate how that evolves
in an expanding universe
we understand thanks to beckenstein and
hawking how entropy behaves in a black
hole and in fact the amount of black
hole entropy far exceeds the ordinary
entropy of ordinary matter and radiation
in our universe by some 12 or more
orders of magnitude so black holes have
incredible amounts of entropy
that is related to their surface area
and that in turn is related to their
mass squared we also know that when a
universe is an expansion entropy behaves
differently entropy can be much smaller
in the past than it is today in fact it
can be much smaller by an exponentially
large amount in other words it could be
as close to zero as you like without it
actually being zero in order to explain
the universe today but the question is
how did the universe get so low energy
in the beginning
if you're going to say that time
progresses because that's the direction
that entropy is increasing then you're
unavoidably led to the conclusion that
entropy was lower in the past that gives
you an error of time but the question is
how low is the entropy in the early
universe and it turns out it has to be
incredibly low
we look at the universe and its earliest
stage compared to today when black holes
dominate the amount of entropy in the
universe it's only about a factor of 12
orders of magnitude the entropy in the
future will be extremely larger or
larger by many many tens of powers of 10
than it is today
in this black hole dominated entropy
phase than it is in the early universe
here's a slide from sean carroll
basically demonstrating that behavior
so we are not in thermal equilibrium as
the boltzmann would have a suggest and
yet the question is how does this
interact with our theory of cosmic
structure formation that we call
inflation not a theory of the extremely
early universe being the creation of the
big bang but how did the properties of
the universe in the inflationary epoch
what does it have to say about entropy
so in a multiverse there are many
perhaps infinite possibilities for how
entropy could be and we may be in a
relatively low entropy state today
because the universe that we inhabit
started off with exponentially smaller
entropy at the beginning of time
there's no proof of that but it is
consistent nevertheless with what we
would observe the question is how did
the entropy get to be so low
so at inflation when we go beyond the
early universe is pointed out by sir
roger penrose past guest on our show the
universe and during inflation had
extremely low entropy but not zero and
that then got
amplified if you will to look like the
universe that we see today so in a
certain sense the randomly fluctuating
universe idea of the multiverse
is actually more likely to have us start
with a high entropy condition
and we know that the entropy of the
universe if inflation took place has to
be extremely low in order to then
inflate and expand via the ordinary
expansion of the universe during
radiation domination etc
and even today to lambda domination and
into the future as what's called the
sitter space which is again an
exponentially accelerating universe
so to get to a 10 to 120th as your
entropy you could start with this very
very low value but you're almost more
likely according to the laws of
thermodynamics to start in high entropy
state rather than a low entropy state so
that's an extremely puzzling observation
now inflation as we've said doesn't
explain
how the universe got started it does
explain how the universe came to be at
least if inflation took place
geometrically flat
but on the other case it does
exceptionally successfully predict the
formation of seeds of structure if it
took place
and it also can create uh via the
so-called reheating mechanism it can
create the matter particles progenitors
that were then later fused into the
earliest nuclei in the universe that
appear in the
formation of big bang nuclear synthesis
so inflation is interesting it solves
many problems but it actually may make
the problem of the low entropy start of
the universe even harder to grapple with
so it could be that the universe had a
boundary in time if you extrapolate from
today back to
some beginning there would be a
beginning it wouldn't go through
smoothly to another universe
or it could be the so-called past
hypothesis is that there is low entropy
in this extremely early universe it
could be that the universe is eternal
and cyclic in a certain sense we don't
know what that means the multiverse
could play a role in its eternality
that inflation is everywhere and always
occurring not as a monetary phenomenon
but it is occurring at all points in the
cosmic superset of all points in space
and time today for the establishment of
the low entropy universe we must then
say that one of the explanations would
be an eternal universe that's always had
always had low entropy until at one
moment it decided to start inflating and
that is a paradigm that we could take
seriously we may believe that by
extrapolating back
the so-called board guth velenken
scenario does have a boundary the
question is is that a signature of when
classical general relativity breaks down
or is it a mandate that we have to then
come up with a theory of quantum gravity
we just don't know but these are
fascinating topics to discuss and
there's a third solution if the universe
was cyclical oscillating into and out of
existence maybe once maybe an infinite
number of times i always say what
happened 15 minutes before the big bang
hawking said that was as meaningless as
asking what's north of the north pole
and in contra distinction he put forth
the no boundary proposal that we talked
about many times
so is there anything before the big bang
it could be a singularity if you can
blindly extrapolate general relativity
back to the infinite past it could be
that there is some sort of phenomenon
that has caused the universe to exist
for eternity either via the so-called
conformal cyclic cosmology of roger
penrose or the so-called bouncing
cosmological models which neither of
which require
a quantum theory of gravity to hold true
and as you know i talk about quite often
the only two regimes where we think
about singularities as being necessary
or at the singularity of a black hole's
core or in the early universe but
neither of which can be possibly
observed even in principle in the
concept of the eternal inflationary
scenario we have a problem that is
solved conventionally via this infinite
number of universes popularized by the
lincoln and linden
cyclic models impose low entropy at the
beginning when the crunch occurs it
doesn't have to be a crunch it could be
a cycle it could be a bounce it could be
a classical bounce and actually the
amount of entropy need be only factors
of a few not exponential not
singularities in the new models of paul
steinhardt and aegis and others so these
are very interesting uh to think about
how it can behave to evade the previous
objections to say the model of tommy
gold and others of a cyclic universe in
which you would actually collapse so
much that you'd start the next cycle
with even higher entropy and add
infinitum the more cycles you add it on
eventually building up infinite entropy
each beginning so
this takes us back to evidence for or
against the multiverse and for or
against cyclic cosmologies i've talked
about this in previous videos that we
could actually observe perhaps the
imprint of a next-door universe via
these patterns in the cosmic microwave
background see here for a video
discussion of that when we talk about
universes beta universes i often like
this analogy of the petri dish with
colonies of bacteria embedded on it and
that the existence of a single bacterium
and its culture could then be used to
postulate that there is a petri dish and
here the analogy is the petri dish is
like the super space of the multiverse
and each culture each individual
bacteriological colony has its own
sort of connection or its own observable
universe in which it can communicate and
not come into contact with another
universe now when it does come into
contact there can be actual
bacteriological battles as i talked
about in losing the nobel prize so this
question can be observed perhaps if
inflation took place it can be
detectable perhaps with the simon's
observatory and the simon's array we'll
talk more about those but the logic that
we employ is that if we observe b mode
polarization we can infer from that a
background stochastic background of
gravitational waves which themselves can
only be created in quantized increments
that would then demonstrate the
quantization of gravity and that would
be further evidence for inflation and as
we let off with guth and linday saying
that in almost every model of inflation
you cannot escape the multiverse in
other words the logic is multiverse
produces inflation produces
gravitational waves produces b modes we
detect those b modes with our
cosmological telescopes the virtue of
the
non-inflationary universes the cyclic
models of siraja penrose and paul
steinhardt collaborators is that they do
not require the observation of
gravitational waves to validate in other
words if you observe a gravitational
wave polarization in the cmb of this
curl mode or [ __ ] type you will actually
be
falsifying the cosmological models of
the eon and the
bouncing or cyclic cosmological models
that is a virtue
and
i like to say we don't know yet what the
future will bring but in the words of
the namesake of the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination sir arthur
c clarke he said the only thing we can
be sure of the future is that it will be
absolutely fantastic
so for now this is brian keating
co-director of the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination at uc san
diego
thanking you for coming along on what we
call 10-minute thesis see you next time
if you like this video be sure to click
here to check out this video about the
inflationary multiverse and its
consequences if you'd like to learn more
about black holes and entropy watch this
video with juan mata cena don't forget
to subscribe